Vienna was home to many of the world's greatest composers,...
...such as Beethoven and Strauss and is known by many as the City of Music.
Stroll to the Vienna State Opera, one of the greatest opera houses in the world.
A little further along the ring is the Hofburg Imperial Palace.
This impressive palace was home to the Habsburg dynasty who ruled the area for centuries.
It currently serves as the official residence for the President of Austria.
The palace is also home to the Austrian National Library...
...where you can examine ancient manuscripts and early copies of some great literary works.
Vienna in the early 1900s attracted some of the greatest painters of the time.
Visit the Belvedere to see some of this work...
...including Gustav Klimt's most famous piece, The Kiss.
Go further back in time to admire paintings by European masters...
...including Raphael, Rubens and Bruegel at the Museum of Art History.
Wander across to the Albertina where you can see original works by Monet, Picasso and Matisse.
Vienna is a truly inspirational city.
It is a city in which you can walk in the footsteps of some of history's greatest minds,...
...explore monumental palaces and cathedrals, and stand before priceless artworks.